let's just uh i want to i want to jump
right in let's get right started yeah
this is from abc3 we are
tv or where tv bronson doj official
confirms
fbi 2019 criminal investigation into
hunter biden still
active and they say a justice department
official
has confirmed a sinclair broadcast group
that the fbi opened up a criminal
investigation into hunter biden and his
associates
back in 2019 focus on allegations of
money laundering
that the probe remains active sinclair
investigative reporter james rosen
has also spoken with a central witness
in these allegations
which suggests that former vice
president joe biden knew more than he
has acknowledged
about his son's overseas dealings tony
babilinski was thrust in the national
spotlight
on the evening of the final presidential
debate it was on that night the former
business associate of hunter biden
claimed democratic nominee joe biden
knew about his son
taking payments from chinese and
ukrainian companies
and strongly suggested he got a kickback
bobalinski discussed
why he feels if elected biden would be
compromised by the chinese government
and much more in an exclusive interview
with rosen
quote the com the compromise they have
is that in the documents they
uh that have been well provided to the
senate to congress
to the department of justice via the fbi
that cefc was effectively loaning money
directly to the biden family
and this is getting swept under the rug
the story is just two hours old right
let me just i don't even know if it's
that i think it's it's relatively new
but
i'm getting picked up i just want to
stress yeah maybe
the democratic presidential nominee
for the most powerful position in the
world
his son is under a criminal
investigation by the fbi
for money laundering and has been for a
year
for over a year while joe biden was
running in the primary
and i can only imagine while trump was
dealing with
you know impeachment so all of this
ukraine stuff was going on imagine
when we started talking about barisma
and all of that impropriety
if news broke that actually yeah hunter
biden's under a criminal investigation
crazy yeah and also he sniffs children
and can't say words right that's too
slow that's a good point i don't know if
you want to vote for him i guess that is
technically you're right
but i can't does anyone really want to
vote for him
nobody wants i don't think anyone wants
to vote for him i think some people are
just scared of trump
agreed they're voting against trump
that's what it is and rightly so
you know trump's not the best well yeah
yeah i mean i i think it's way better i
think it's a better option but i could
see why people would be turned off by
him for sure
yeah i just wish she was nicer you seem
quiet sam what are you thinking about oh
no
i feel like he's not nice but that's
also so much of his strength because
his base just loves the weight and
myself included right i
love the way that he stands up to the
media so i shouldn't even just say his
base but i think the american people in
general are so sick of dominant media i
got to give a brief shout out to tim to
you
because you're like the only person i
know that kept at that charisma thing
and like two months ago three months ago
four months ago you were talking about
it there's a bunch of going over my i
didn't know what you meant
half the time it'd be like what this
thing is yeah let me state
concept let me help everyone understand
oh no yeah
hunter biden got hired to be on the
board of directors for a company called
barisma energy founded by a man named by
michola zlachevsky
zlatchevsky was under several active
investigations confirmed by matt taibi
13 to 14 according to some ukrainian
officials
this man founder of barisma his his
dealings
could have resulted in and potentially
did
result in active investigations and
inactive investigations of barisma and
all of its board members as well
including hunter biden
rosemont rosemont seneca was was uh the
name of the company that was receiving
money
blue star strategies was a pr firm that
represented them and had and had emails
sent to the state department
complaining about the investigation
there's a bunch of separate instances
and i i want to be careful so i'm not
going to go through them specifically
where you can follow this timeline where
this pr firm was like yo what's going on
why are we being investigated we're not
doing anything wrong hey let them know
hunter biden's on the board
oh wow joe biden shows up after blue
star strategies was on some
white house phone call he shows up and
says
fire him or you're not getting the money
now as most of you know
trump couldn't do this either and
neither could joe biden withhold aid
and threaten a country now they complain
that donald trump threatened to withhold
aid from ukraine
and to investigate joe biden that was
the basis of the impeachment part of it
joe biden was literally on video saying
i
told them to their faces i will withhold
the aid and they said you can't do that
and he said call the president see what
he says
one billion dollars in in guaranteed
loans you will not get
unless you fire this guy and matt taibi
in his writing he says he contacted
officials long-standing liberal
journalist matt how you
mind you formerly of rolling stone said
potentially 13 to 14 active and inactive
investigations against this guy
the when joe biden got this guy fired he
goes sure enough
you know son of a [ __ ] guy gets fired
the new guy who came in cleared
zlatchevsky of all wrongdoing
zlatski was then able to return to
ukraine and it wasn't until 2018
all of a sudden he had to flee the
country again when more corruption
charges emerged
so why was hunter biden getting between
50 and 83
000 a month to be on the board of a
company for which he has no experience
doesn't speak the language
and then his dad intervened and fired
the prosecutor now the mainstream news
repeatedly says it's fake news it's not
true
and we know they're lying it's it's it's
it is
so insane the lies i mean at the very
least how would they know it was fake
the most you can know is that you don't
know if it's real or you don't know if
it's fake i'll tell you this
i'll tell you this at the very least
don't you think it warrants
a special prosecutor in a three year
long
maybe maybe you can get bob mueller on
this one yeah man i don't i don't know
tim maybe hunter is just a savant and he
was he started there as a janitor and he
was writing on the chalkboards and he
just knew everything about energy he
needed to know they're like let's give
him a 50 to 80
000 a month position despite the fact
that he literally has no formal training
anything related to this field and now
man i tell you what i was watching the
five earlier and sometimes i wonder if
like
they put juan williams on that show just
to get someone to like
you know like a punching bag because the
dude just
he's very emotional and clearly doesn't
know what he's talking about
and so they're all laughing at him like
this is so weird to watch like jesse
waters is laughing at him how dummy is
not like
that's kind of mean that's very mean so
so one william's like
i read the wall street journal it says
joe biden was not officially on any
roles
and and then they're all laughing at him
and they're like because it was you the
accusation is not that joe biden joined
a company in china when he was vice
president
the accusation is that while joe biden
was vice president he flew his son
hunter-byte on air force two to china
for private equity uh investment deals
yeah that literally happened
and then later on we learned that one of
these deals ended up getting
a five million dollar loan to the biden
family tony babilinski got offended
by this and said they went behind my
back and made millions of dollars
i wonder if the reason bob yolinski's
coming out is because he realized when
these emails got leaked
they straight up they they they knifed
him in the back he's supposed to be this
guy who's working with them
to do this big deal they tell him nah
we're not going to do it then he sees in
the email it's like we get five million
dollars
in you know a forgivable loan with no
with no interest he's like
what yeah where's my cut seriously i'm
dropping the documents
and then he published audio he gave to
tucker where he caught he's on the phone
with these guys and they're like tony
you're gonna bury all of us man yeah
yep i think they realized they screwed
this dude over
and now i'm not i'm not gonna impugn the
honor
of tony babilinski i don't know why he's
coming forward now but i do want to
point this out
if he knew that he was meeting with joe
biden in secret it's like part of the
story he told you like
in in in the bar and like no one can see
them and they're talking
if he knew the goal was to peddle
influence he's only coming out now
he waited this long he complains about
them making money to be fair
he said that he tried everything to stop
it when he realized they weren't doing a
legitimate deal it was an influence deal
and then he found out later they made
millions of dollars in the chinese
behind his back
so his story is he thought he stopped it
and then he found out later they went
forward with this influence peddling
and he's mad about it and respectable i
mean the dude's a veteran i got no
reason to it's also possible that he
would have been
implicated if he didn't work with the
fbi on this
i think so i don't know though i mean
perhaps
or perhaps the fbi is
got a bunch of crooked people in it and
they're not going to go after the bidens
because they hate trump so much
entirely political dude i tell you what
man i
i can't imagine that the things we're
seeing to this scale
are just i don't know how to describe it
man but you've got some
deeply crooked people in this country
and
you know seeing what happened with glenn
greenwald the intercept
there are evil hey this is this is the
craziest thing to me
how do you describe someone who knows
they're lying and cheating to help
corrupt individuals
to stop because they hate trump like how
do you describe someone that's willing
to subvert the will of the people
that's that's that's the antithesis of
this country
of democratic values of liberal
liberalism like classical liberalism the
idea of the individual
but not even just classical liberalism
but basic human decency
i mean if you were a monarchist or a
or a despotist if that's a such a thing
or maybe a feudalist
you'd absolutely love your lords lording
over you with unlimited power
and you'd want to serve them and just do
whatever they want if you're an
authoritarian or a communist i suppose
there are people in this country in
media and in government
who know that joe biden did these things
and they're going to protect him because
orange man bad well this is the irony of
it though i actually think under a lot
of those systems people would be more
likely
to say this person even though they're
in a position of authority over me
they're hopelessly corrupt and
i might not abide by that uh well i mean
they would because the system would
require that they would
but it seems as if when you're in a
democratic system and the leaders are
chosen
you have to justify their behavior more
often to justify your decision to have
chosen them in the first place
so i think people are more likely to get
on board and rationalize this kind of
horrible behavior i just think
you've got blind tribalist zealots well
i think you're undermining the public's
faith in our intelligence community and
our media institutions good the nsa
yeah great absolutely and you know and
security you know
what's really funny is like uh when i
was reading some of the criticisms about
glenn greenwald
i'm just like i'm right there you know
there's a bunch of journalists who all
of a sudden have become staunchly
anti-democratic party for some reason
yep and so people are like tim pool's
right wing and i thought about it and
i'm like
there's a lot of reasons but a really
good example is the media is a
propaganda arm of the democratic party
and there's no denying it at this point
literally no denying it at all now i'm
gonna go up the chain to the council on
foreign relations
that that's where joe biden was when he
said uh
son of a big i got fired he was at a
meeting for the cfr
and he was like so i go and i got a
billion dollar loan and i say fi if you
don't fire the prosecutor you're not
getting the money
it's all on video and that that company
i don't know to be honest and
if anyone in the chat knows like how
where the funding goes to these media
organizations because a lot of them get
funding from the same places like
i don't think i i think i think we've
got
cultists man here i'll tell you what
i'll tell you what
every single thing they do they project
they say 100
and it's and it's bad like you know uh
trump is a death cult
it's like dude trump's got his
sycophants for sure but
most people don't even think the name
trump on an average basis it's just
oh yeah those free trade agreements are
bad and they're going to vote for him
but also i think that trump's critics
talk about him more than his supporters
do
yeah definitely that's been one of the
strangest things about the past four
years is trump is just on everyone's
mind all the time and it's not voluntary
the media is constantly talking about
him and it makes sense to talk about the
president pretty frequently they have in
the past but
not like trump and you could say well
he's an unprecedented uh
president he does a lot of things that
we haven't seen in the past but
it clearly goes past that it's a very
strange obsession and they like to
nitpick and we were talking about the
two scoops thing earlier
right right right yeah and then well so
that was meant to be silly it was kind
of meant to be silly
pepper shaker thing was serious well and
also what they were claiming as soon as
he got into the white house that he like
removed a bust of martin luther king jr
like just cartoon villains
not even true yeah yeah yeah exactly it
was like it's it's in a photo like
the story comes out they're like he
removed martin luther king and the photo
they use shows it like on the desk well
that's the thing
even if that was the kind of thing trump
wanted to do don't you think he would
know better
than like so this is aren't they always
accusing right-wingers of
dog whistling like wouldn't be more
subtle about it yeah only they can hear
which is so insane because like if i am
a racist with a racist base
wouldn't i just say racist things why
would i say things that my base doesn't
understand or think are racist when
they're supposedly racist but that like
democrats will get mad about anyway that
seems like a lose-lose
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you